says the guy that a minute ago off
camera went i have dentist
he didn't say this
some words are unknown he's got dentists
all over his face i thought he just went
to the dentist as well
because then i haven't been in like five
years do you have dentist
i have done yeah i haven't been like an
issue you need to sort out or
you want to make a mold because my my uh
why is that so [ __ ] funny chris it's
[Laughter]
what the [ __ ] was it again it was like
i hate this guy it sounds like he was
served on risotto from the breast
and one wine before milk yeah it was
quite you know it felt quite happy
that was like instead of baby food it
was risotto baby food
anyway but i'm a dentist i have dentists
yeah have we talked about the japan
dentist experience we haven't because
what is that i went to an english
dentist oh okay
meline was like yeah they speak all
english and they use american practices
that are better than japan are they
better than japanese
the american way apparently is better
than the japanese apparently japanese
dentists have a
bad rap i've heard they're pretty bad
it's it's not that they're bad like i
went the other day it's a japanese one
and it's like it's not that they're bad
it's just they're a lot more like
ruthless when it comes to like cleaning
your teeth like you know because they
use that like
really like tiny thin like high pressure
water holes
and it kind of makes it type of sound i
hate that yeah
they use that right like all dentists do
but they go like
hard they just like just hi they sound
really nice when they're like asking you
to open your mouth right like
i didn't realize like japanese den just
had a bad rap but it makes sense now the
first time i went to a dentist japanese
dentist
he said don't worry i learned in canada
it's like exactly it's like a it's an
advertising point if you're training
yeah in america or so they're all
trained in canada
front and center of their marketing yeah
because the
american dental system is actually
pretty good if you can afford it
which is yeah always there's the cash
that's the biggest yikes um
but yeah no it's really good i mean i
i've cause you know
no one tells you you gotta go to the
dentist by the way until until your
teeth are like [ __ ] do you like i
guess i should go dentist
so i just totally forgot to go to the
dentist for how long it's like five
years
five years without dentists people like
you that create the big book of british
spanish
my teeth are fine 4k
no they're all right i never had
problems and they i went and they were
like so why are you going twice
so um i when my when i jet like when my
mouth is resting
my like bite is pretty deep like it i
mean you have this as well right yeah
so just to stop my teeth from grinding
in my sleep why are you laughing like a
rabid dog
no it's just like when you're resting
you know some people when you rest it's
way
i think it's when you have like a
particular [ __ ] yeah it's kind of yeah
when i sleep it's kind of uncomfortable
to close my mouth
yeah what do you dream about to make you
do that are you like
not for the [ __ ] about playing apex
raid of shadows in your sleep
shadows he makes real shadows
there's about four games in one
apex raid of shadows my favorite game
you're you're in touch with the kids
right
you try and be a [ __ ] boober on
purpose
on [ __ ] purple you play that apex
rate of shadows